hey guys it is the 19th of sep tember my
name is just and we're back with the
Australian edition of games but news
usable for developer the Coalition has
confirmed that the game will feature
split-screen campaign co-op fun pc
technical director mike rana told pc
gamer that while the feature is quite
difficult to support from a development
perspective it was a labor of love the
studio elected to include the
split-screen campaign called feature
after hearing some feedback saying they
wanted it rana explained we have to deal
with multiple inputs we have to deal
with focus we have to deal with you I
placement that extra work especially
when having to also consider all the
resolutions and aspect ratios a pc can
have maybe why most big games nowadays
don't typically support split-screen
co-op the new Metal Gear survive trailer
has not been received all that well by
you guys ork redeem himself Metal Gear
survive was announced during games come
in August it's a multiplayer stealth
game set in the same universe as Metal
Gear Solid 5 the new gameplay trailer
shows off co-op gameplay with a team
facing off against a nasty zombies
Kadima has been quick to distance
himself from the Konami created game
saying that's nothing to do with me
adding the Metal Gear games are about
political fiction and espionage where to
zombies fit in with that if I had worked
on the game it would have had mex in it
evidently you guys aren't all that keen
on the idea either or perhaps you just
aren't all that keen on Konami at the
time of writing the trailer has 18 point
six thousand dislike and early 1200
likes Konami who said that Metal Gear
survive will cost around 30 bucks and
it's due to arrive on xbox one ps4 and
PC and 2017 finally the witcher 3 is not
going to be one of the games patch to
take advantage of the upcoming
playstation 4 pro soda broke dread told
Eurogamer since we want to fully focus
on cyberpunk 2077 and gwen and
converting the witcher 3 wild hunt from
a full HD game into a 4k one would be
too much of a time and resource
consuming process we decided not to
release an edition of wild
come to supporting the new features of
PlayStation pro if you absolutely must
play it in 4k the game does offer 4k
support on PC be sure to head to
GameSpot's the stories on battlefield
one destiny and all our coverage of TGS
and i'll be back with more news tomorrow